so the question is when is the best time
to take vitamin
d what you have to realize is vitamin d
is a fat soluble vitamin what does that
mean it means that you're going to have
better absorption
like between 30 and 50 better absorption
if you take it with fat now there are
vitamin d supplements that already
contain
fat within the supplement itself i'll
put a link down below of one that i
recommend
but if you're going to take vitamin d as
a supplement without the fat
consume your vitamin d with a meal but
make sure there's some fat avocado
maybe some type of meat that has
saturated fat olive oil
mct oil nuts dairy
egg any of the fats because you're going
to increase your absorption by 30 to 50
percent
more now there's one more point i want
to talk about if you have a
sleeping problem you may want to try
taking your vitamin d right before
bed and here's why vitamin d can help
increase
your non-rem sleep that's the deep delta
wave sleep that occurs
in the first half of sleep vitamin d
receptors are
located in the master clock that
controls the circadian rhythms it's
called the super chasmatic nuclei
a very interesting word it has receptors
for vitamin d
so there's a huge connection between
vitamin d deficiency
and sleep problems also there's vitamin
d receptors in your brain stem
which also have a lot to do with your
sleep cycles
and on top of that and i just did a
video on this
vitamin d can help reduce your cortisol
levels
your stress levels so you may want to
try taking vitamin d
right before you go to bed to see if
that might help you now for most people
if you're taking vitamin d right before
bed you're going to do fine you're going
to sleep better
a small percentage of people it may wake
them
up they might need to take it earlier in
the day but
if you have a sleep problem you may want
to just try it there's a couple other
vitamins that you can also add
if you have a sleeping problem vitamin
b5 which has a lot to do with lowering
cortisol
folate which is a b vitamin that can
also help your sleep cycles
and vitamin b1 especially if you have a
lot of worry
and you're thinking at night and you
just can't turn it off
so if you have a sleeping problem try
taking vitamin d right before you go to
bed
and comment down below and let me know
how it worked
hey before you go if you're benefiting
from
any of my content i would love
to hear about your success story please
share it
in the link down below